good evening ladies and gentlemen it's 7
30. welcome to the review committee on
the 5th of october 2021
before we start the meeting i'll make
the emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the whole entrance entrance
doors turn right walk straight past the
canteen and through the external doors
on the right and out to the car park
which is our assembly point
please do not delay your evacuate
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the buildings
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded
would you please switch off mobiles or
please turn them to silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and antibacterial wipes on the
tables if you do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations
those abstaining from voting will be
noted by officers
so moving on to agenda item number one
apologies for absence apologies have
been received from councillor robin dre
councillor gary myers and councillor
james newport are there any other
apologies members
okay
gender item two substitute members
councillor bob milne will be
substituting for council robin dre
councillor carol weston will be
substituting for council gary myers and
councillor chris stanley will be
substituting for councillor james
newport
are there any other substitute members
right thank you
non-members attending
i can see councillor williams and
councillor f day
a gender item four minutes of the
meeting held on the 7th of september
2021
are the minutes agreed members
council constable
they could cancel the constable that's
noted and will be amended
are there any other
amendments
okay are the minutes agreed with the
amendment proposed by council constable
okay thank you members they agreed
agenda item five to receive declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest members
none indicated thank you
agenda item six
is the regulation of investigatory
powers act 2000 or the ripper act
members would you please note that in
recommendation 2
there is reference made to section 4.8
this should be section 4.6
okay i would now invite the assistant
director of people and communities
louisa moss
to present the report
thank you chair evening councillors so
just to iterate the purpose of this
report according to home office code and
guidance is to update elected members
on the ripper policy and also to report
on the ripper activity within the
council
and just to summarize report that our
reproductivity remains at nil over the
last year and the report itself just for
clarity
um is as it was last year as well with
the a minor amendment of a name change
as detailed in the report i do detail in
this report that the ripper policy
itself is due for further review
following an inspection in january and
that review is still ongoing and as you
can see it's tabled as a key decision
for later on this month
so the policy that you see appendix to
this report itself is the current one
with the only amendment being noted is
the name change itself so i'll just open
it up to questions now for me
catch them
so
uh yes um
i have a couple of questions one the
main one is is rather about repo because
we haven't used it for the last 10 years
so my question is that the council's
policy
is
so far been making little use of what's
potentially a useful piece of
legislation designed for permitting
where appropriate surveillance or
technical support to deal with issues of
public safety and the protection of
property
and
from that point of view i appreciate the
uh
the comment
uh that uh
using it disproportionately
could lead to problems in the reputation
of the council but
my question is do we not consider
not using it at all could also have the
same effect if it was not used where
appropriate
and
the last point i will make is this
at the moment we were talking last year
about a district-wide cctv system which
would have 24 7 monitoring that is a
passive evidence collecting system
so you don't need permissions
to use that you would need permissions
of course if you used it for anything
else for a specific purpose but the
legislation is designed for that
now
what i'm what i'm now saying is that
we're not using this
and we have a policy which is tantamount
to not using it
my question is do not consider that that
in itself is a risk and perhaps we ought
to review that
and also do something about the
um
what has now become not a district cctv
system
it's gone back to a couple of parishes
one's already rejected it because of the
funding formula
so now we have a problem because we
could add a mobile system to that
but because we can't because we haven't
got it although we could use smaller
systems if we wanted to now we've had
disorder in rayleigh serious assaults
criminal damage there's graffiti all
around the town and we've had fly
tipping which we've had some success in
dealing with
directly
but
my question is that should we not be
considering
making
slightly better use of it not overused
but just now and again where appropriate
thank you
i refer directly to direct surveillance
which is ripper as you know which is
covert surveillance rather than the
other cctv
but
probably to put the question back
because obviously it does depend under
what circumstances
you feel we should um use ripa more for
as you know um counselor
it it there is a threshold to ripper for
which we have to obviously have regard
to especially around the custodial
sentence
and also obviously it has to get
judicial approval and i'm not saying we
shouldn't use it but obviously it it's
under what circumstances we use it and
it's that that we have to take into
consideration
before we do so and i agree there are
some circumstances where we might
consider it such as fly tipping um using
covert surveillance but as you say most
of our successes so far have been using
overt methods and we're using other
methods accordingly so
where we've used it before as you
appreciate and i think i've mentioned
before is back in 2011 and prior to that
has been on benefit fraud which is now
all done by dwp and they do all the
investigatory and collection of evidence
and the food work for that
so
i i absolutely understand um but it's
under what circumstances we use it for
and to take the truth you know
at the moment
it would be fly-tipping asb again would
depend on what public order offences
we're looking at and whether the
custodial sentence is meeting the
threshold or not and obviously we work
in partnership a lot and use other
agencies for those actions so
um i know what you say but as you say we
do take each circumstance in its own
merits really and look at the threshold
what an old minor front rayleigh is now
suffering from the graffiti artist who's
using silver paint and large signatures
now that's not going to be
presumably possibly result in any kind
of custodial sentence the last time
someone was caught doing that they had a
little bit of community service to do
but um there are a couple of spots to do
with anti-social drinking and the
smashing of bottles and play areas which
are dangerous young children
and those kind of things we've already
got our local police have actually paid
casual attention to those areas
there's a couple of those spots could
easily have something that could collect
evidence
but there's nothing there so we it just
goes on with criminal damage now being
formed with these silver signatures
appearing i think i just did marx and
spencer's the other week
anyway thank you thank you
councillor mrs shaw
through your chair thank you um
sue louisa appendix a the very last page
62.1
are all these names correct i thought
leslie had left
or am i mistaken
she has left yes
you're correct she has left yeah i just
want so we are all the other names
correct on here or do it are they all
um yeah apologies members leslie athey
has left but all the other names are
accurate right thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman um
just a question louisa um
what is the cost to our council
for this and is there any possibility
around sharing the resource in the
training with another authority
um the cost of the training that we had
last year was for 19 delegates including
all um sort of authorizing officers
applicants um portfolio holder and the
cost was
1750 pounds for 19 delegates and
absolutely there's always scope for
economies of scale to share with other
local authorities and we carry out our
training every two years so the
opportunity will be in a couple of years
time to reach out to
other partners
thank you
thank you council foster please
thank you chairman just a question which
may be based on my uh ignorance shall we
say of the policies but um and god
forbid it should ever be necessary but
in the policy is there an element
covering surveillance of employees of
the council
um good question i can't answer that
it's not something we've covered in our
ripper policy that's for sure
and i can get back to you on that but
it's not covered on this concept the
reason i ask has not just been awkward
it could probably change the context
of some of the activities
necessary
i'll speak with our hr service and get
back to you
thank you
no one else is indicating
so members
there are two recommendations at 10.1
and 10.2 on page 2.3 of the report
10.1 is proposed that committee resolves
to note the council's annual usage of
ripper
members is this noted
10.2 it's proposed that the committee
recommends to council that the
amendments to the council's ripper
policy set out in section 4.6 above
are approved
can those members in favor
please raise their hands
can those members against please raise
their hands
has been uh approved
item seven on the agenda is the key
decisions document and what i'll do is
and our
traditional way is to go through each
key decision and ask if anyone
wishes to
raise an issue or talk about it so the
first one is
on page
two of the report zero three two one the
suspension of parking charges on
saturdays before christmas
any
comments or observations
okay okay
on the same page zero 0-421 voluntary
sector grant allocations
2022-2023
any observations or comments
okay
on page 3
0 8 21 waste transfer arrangements
any observations or
comments
okay
thank you
zero nine two one
subject is to agree the changes to the
ripper policy and ripper social media
guide
any comments or observations
1021
subject is to agree a council
anti-social behaviour policy
any comments or observations
thank you
now move on to item eight
um the work plan
um
so
if we go through the work plan
okay so
the
[Music]
hopefully got the email from um sonya
the meeting that's due to be held on the
2nd november is now moved back to the
9th of november and that will be for the
audit to receive the report on the audit
of the overview and scrutiny function
and
that report
or the draft report is in with officers
at the moment so
what i propose to do is to organize a
pre-meeting of members before because i
think it's going to be something that'd
be quite meaty for us to
to get into and go through the
recommendations so it'll be be a zoom
call so that would probably yeah
councilman
yeah
okay
on the 30th of november we will receive
the treasury management mid-year review
report
we've got a holiday in january
but we may add extra stuff in there
8th of february will be the treasury
management strategy statement
and then
first of march we've got the community
safety partnership and the disposals
framework and i'll be writing out to
invite members to
form a member working group to look at
the disposals framework
and then finally on the 5th of april
we've got our annual report and our
engagement with residents and other
stakeholders
one of if you remember back to the last
meeting when we had mr hoffman
presenting about the parks for nature
and we recommended that
we would have a member working groups to
look in within the wards
that recommendation is going toward to
the executive uh on the ninth so
hopefully when that hopefully that will
get approved and then we can start
setting those working groups up
council mrs shaw
thank you chairman just on your point
about the review pre-meetings for
members who didn't couldn't attend i
think it's a very good idea that we
start these up so thank you for doing
that
i can't take credit because it wasn't
actually my ideas
from the training and i suspect that it
will come well i don't know but i
suspect it will be in the report but i
i've personally found it useful
thank you but you instigated it so thank
you very much okay thank you
okay thank you members um that is the
final agenda item
so the meeting is closed at
17 49
thank you for your attendance